hello everyone i'm rich stocks in 1997 i
heard a cassette tape by veterinarian
and naturopathic physician dr joe
wallach the title of that lecture was
dead doctors don't lie
dr wallick's books and audios have now
sold hundreds of millions of copies
making dead doctors don't lie the most
popular health lecture in history so not
only did i begin following dr wallach's
nutritional and wellness advice i began
sharing his message with everyone i knew
25 years later i'm still sharing dr
wallock's message and i'm excited to
share it with you today the full dead
doctors don't lie audio lecture is
available on our website
mineraldoctor.com mineraldoctor.com it's
free of charge you can go there and
listen to the same lecture that i heard
25 years ago we have two other websites
that might be of interest to you i'm
also a bible teacher so i have a
a website dedicated to bible teaching
and ministry and that is rich stocks.org
rich stocks.org and then i have a
website dedicated to those who want to
reduce maintain and control their weight
and that is simple3slim.com
if you'll go to mineraldoctor.com the
website that we're speaking about today
uh the first two things i would suggest
you do right there on our homepage is
take these two steps
number one take our free health
evaluation it's digital it's online
and then schedule a free phone
consultation with one of dr wallach's
associates and they will help you find
out what
what nutrition you might be lacking and
what can help you to support you and
your health goals your health and
wellness goals so here is a very short
summary
of the hour hour and a half lecture that
i heard years ago 25 years ago dead
doctors don't lie here are the eight
bullet points that i've summarized for
you number one
there are 90 essential nutrients that
every human being needs every day to
still stay healthy that is what this
shirt i'm wearing today 90 for life 90
essential nutrients that every human
being needs from preconception
up until the time of death
90 essential nutrients every human being
needs every day of their life for every
nutrient that's missing
there are up to 10 deficiency diseases
so 90 nutrients up to 10 deficiency
diseases per nutrient that's 900
diseases that dr wallock as a
veterinarian learned that he could and
we can use this word legally with
animals he could prevent and cure
diseases and animals with the proper
nutrition now we're not allowed to say
that none of these products we're going
to talk about today we're not allowed to
say they'll cure you and even if we were
allowed we're not going to say that they
are simply to support support
and promote
better health and we're going to talk
about that today
so bullet point number two of these 90
essential nutrients and here was the
thing that shocked me most when i heard
his lecture
of the 90 essential nutrients 60 of
these
two-thirds are minerals
two-thirds i didn't know there were 60
minerals in the world now i should from
my high school chemistry class that was
the periodic table
that you know is up on the wall in your
chemistry class
those are the elements all the elements
that are known to man that exists well
minerals all of these minerals that
we're talking about are on that periodic
table but i did not know that two-thirds
we hear a lot about vitamins when i was
a little kid ironically my mother would
bring me my little flintstone chewable
vitamin
every night after i was already in bed
and as soon as she turned her head i kid
you not i would toss that vitamin
underneath the bed
and one day eventually people get around
to
sweeping out from underneath their bed
well there were piles and piles
of these vitamins and now i'm in the
vitamin business so to speak for 25
years very
ironic but
60 of the 90 nutrients
are minerals not vitamins bullet point
number three
without minerals vitamins have no
function in the human body that was a
shocker to me
you can just pile on the vitamins but if
the minerals are not present
when those vitamins are consumed
the vitamin has no function there's
nothing it can do
and they're useless i have a pharmacist
friend who says it like this he says
that minerals are sparks of electricity
well that makes sense think about it if
you know anything about batteries we
have cadmium batteries what's cadmium
that's a mineral we have nickel
batteries what's nickel nickel is a
mineral
so what's the significance well those
are the sparks of electricity
they are the sparks of electricity
that allow your body to utilize the
other nutrients like vitamins amino
acids and those sorts of things
bullet point number four
there is not a single plant
or animal or human being that can
produce even one of these 60 minerals
that's very important
now if you were to go out in the
sunlight today
that's a bright sunshiny day here where
we are filming this video
and
if i were to go out in the sun my body
can produce a vitamin most of you know
what that is it can produce some vitamin
d there are some animals that can
produce i think a hamster
seems to me like there's certain
vitamins a hamster can produce i don't
know that's not part of my teaching
today but the point being there are
plants there are animals there are
humans that can produce
some vitamins even amino acids there are
three essential amino acids
if your body if you consume two of those
your body can produce the third one on
its own but let me say this again
there is not a single plant there's not
a single animal and there is not one
human being that can produce even one
of these 60 essential minerals
so two-thirds of the nutrition we need
are minerals and yet our body cannot
produce
a single one of those what does that
tell you they have to be consumed
these minerals have to be consumed well
unfortunately here's bullet point number
five if the minerals are not in the soil
they're not in our food
if they're not in the grass
that the cow eats
they're not in the cow when you eat the
cow you're not getting any minerals
and even if you've planted a garden from
row to row
those minerals vary
minerals run in veins dr wallick says it
like this they run in veins like
chocolate ripple ice cream
if we all if all these minerals were
just uniform blanket you know in the
crust of the earth we'd all go out in
our backyard and dig up gold today well
you probably don't have gold in your
backyard why not because minerals run
in veins
from row to row field to field nation to
nation state to state
so
the minerals are not in the soil they're
not in our food so no matter how well we
think we're eating here's where many
people are deceived
no matter how well we think we're eating
it is impossible
to get the 90 essential nutrients from
our foods
that's the reason
and
furthermore well let me just say this
about that there are a lot of people i
said a lot of people were deceived a lot
of people say oh i eat well
so i don't need to take any nutrients
well
it's we see here it's impossible they
don't understand that two-thirds of the
nutrition they need are minerals and if
those minerals aren't in the soil even
if you're a vegetarian if they're not in
the soil
and you're eating these pristine plants
or what about organic
all organic means
is no pesticides
eating organic food now if you can
afford it do it i do it and i believe
you should
it's good it's cleaner food but it does
not contain one extra mineral
over and above non-organic foods just so
you know that organic eating organic
does not add
nutrition to your diet
so we need to be very clear on that if
the nutrients are not in the soil
they're not in the food
and you're not getting them and
according to u.s senate document 264.
now this was written in 1936 think about
that that's a long time ago
as far back as
1936 our government here in the united
states of america we knew that our farm
soils were depleted
of these essential minerals these vital
nutrients
what does that mean that means that our
foods
have been starved of nutrition
and we've known this since 1936 so no
matter how well you think you eat you
are not cannot and you are not getting
the nutrition you need from your food
it's not possible bullet point number
six minerals must be in a plant form
for our bodies to absorb them
i like what dr wallach says
he says you can't get all the minerals
you need by licking rocks
well minerals that's what they are
they're elements they're rocks they're
metals they're found in the crust of the
earth
but you can't just go get a lick or rock
and get all the minerals you need why
because you cannot your body is not made
to absorb minerals in a metallic form
now once the plants the plants can do
that plants
through photosynthesis
they
can extract these nutrients these
minerals from the soil
and you can have a healthy plant
and but our bodies can't break down
those metallic minerals so what do we
have to do well we have to consume those
minerals in a plant form where the plant
has already broken down the
metallic form of the minerals now it's
in a form that our body can absorb
and that's what dr wallach's minerals
are all about bullet point number seven
dr wallach's mineral mine is the only
known source of all 60
essential minerals in a plant derived
form i've been there many times there in
emory county utah
it is there could be other mines in the
world
but this is the only one that we know of
the only known mine in the world there
could be some mines dr wallach has found
some that might have 30 minerals 40
minerals but he's only found one place
on the planet
where we can get all
of these essential minerals
in a plant form
and he has the rights to that mineral
mine
and that's what makes dr wallick's
products so unique and so effective dr
wallach's youngevity that's the name of
dr wallach's company is the only company
and the only products in the world
that offer all 90 essential nutrients
you could go and start trying to piece
together by doing what we call
fractionated nutrition
and we're very much
not fans
of fractionated nutrition what is that
well
the doctor says you have a calcium
deficiency what do people do right down
to the health food store buy a bottle of
calcium well
the calcium has to work together with
the other 89 essential nutrients that's
why a lot of times you'll see with
calcium they've added some vitamin d
they've added some boron well it's more
than that
all these 90 essential nutrients work
synergistically
they all work together
and so
that's what makes naturawalic's product
so unique so effective and that's why
this is the only place in the world
where you can get all 90 essential
nutrients because of those plant-derived
minerals bullet point number eight
the simplest and the best way to make
sure you're getting all 90 essential
nutrients is with dr wallock's healthy
body start pack now here to my right
you can get
all 90 essential nutrients
in just three products say why don't you
put them in one product well
because some of these are oils
and some of these are liquids we know
again from basic chemistry class oils
and liquids do not mix
and also calcium is a nutrient you need
far more of
than most of these other trace minerals
there are major minerals there are trace
minerals and there are rare earths so we
separate the calcium so let me say it
again you can get all 90 essential
nutrients that dr wallach teaches about
that you're going to hear when you
listen to that dead doctors don't lie
lecture
right here in these three products say
what's this fourth product here well the
calcium some people prefer in a liquid
form some people prefer in a powder
form so that's what that is so here are
the three products there are over
235 nutrients in this healthy body start
pack we're going to have a separate
video
just about the healthy body start pack
but i want to at least
show it to you and mention it to you
today again you can find this it's
available on our website
mineraldoctor.com i want to invite you
again go to that website and take the
two steps i mentioned at the beginning
take the free health evaluation that's
how you will know the deficiencies that
you might have in your body when you
take that health evaluation and then
schedule your free phone consultation
with one of dr wallach's associates and
they will help you they're not going to
try to put a high pressure sales pitch
on you and all of this they're going to
help you determine
the the
health pack that is best for you we're
going to talk about some other health
packs that dr wallach has where he adds
products that you may need more of to
the healthy body start pack so we are
out of time for today again visit
mineraldoctor.com
and we're looking forward to hearing
from you friend very soon